نعم انطلقت المسيره الخضراء قبل اقل من 10
دقائق من الان الساعه 1:00 بالتوقيت توقيت
الرياض وتوقيت الدوحه وكما نشاهد الاخضر
في كل مكان وهناك حمام وهناك جمهور كبير
يستعد هذه المباراه التي ستقام هنا في هذا
ستاد مدينه المدينه الاعلاميه او اديوكيشن
سيتي هنا في الدوحه والتي ستنطلق وبين
بولندا والسعوديه طبعا وهناك حماس كبير
الكثير اذا اخذنا الكاميرا
وكيف هو الجمهور والجمهور دائما هنا مستعد
يعني ما توقعت احمد اند يوصل الى منطقه
استاد طب ثلاث ساعات من قيام المباراه
ولكنهم ما زال متحمسين شكرا هذا العالم
السعودي وهم دائما متحمسون اذا كان معنا
مجال احمد من اي منطقه
عن طريق معبر ثروه الكثير على فكره احمد
وصلوا الى هذه المنطقه الى هذا ستاد
تحديدا من معبر سلوى هناك حشود على هذا
المعبر التي تستمر الوفود او المشجعين
السعوديين يصلون الى هذه المنطقه وشاهدنا
يعني الحماس والفرح في وجوههم انظروا الى
هذا الشاب شو اسمك حسن من جده حسن من جده
انت كيف وصلت انا جيت والله عن طريق
الطيران متى صباح مباراه الارجنتين الحمد
لله
[تصفيق]
اخر شوطه وتق- شو توقعاتكم
كلمه كلمه سيدي صاحب السمو الملكي الامير
محمد بن سلمان
[تصفيق]
عصام واليوم نحن بملحمه عربيه اسلاميه
قويه بعيد عن كل انواع كره القدم اليوم
نعيش اسره واحده بعد فوز السعوديه اكتشفنا
ان العرب والمسلمين قلبه واحد وان شاء
الله قدامك
شكرا محمد عفوا نشاهد كذلك الفوز الكثير
من يتحدث الكثير منهم تحدث عن فوز عربي في
ارض عربيه وهذا مهم جدا وهناك الحماس
الكبير من الشباب الذين اتوا من جميع
مناطق المملكه من جميع الطرق يعني ليس فقط
عن طريق مطار حمد ولكن عن طريق معبر سلوى
وهناك او مناطق اخرى من المنطقه الشرقيه
اشخاص قبل قليل يعني اذا برده معنى وقت
احمد ولكن
وصلت اول امس
شايف الاجواء الاجواء رائعه والتنظيم رائع
وكل شيء في البطوله رائع صراحه توقعات 1-0
السعوديه وباذن الله فرحتاه اليوم هيه
[تصفيق]